Just to explain the gratitude [music]
and the happiness that this
brother of ours is facing. Just 10
minutes ago, he couldn't stand.
Alhamdulillah, through your donations to
Waqf Forever, today, not only is he
standing, but he has a smile on his
face. Jazakum Allah khairan to each and
every one of you who dignified our
brother, our father from Gaza.
Donate to Waqf Forever and help change
lives today.
>> [music]
>> As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Wow, Americans, your children,
your kids are dying.
Not only does the Israelis fund
pedophile islands where they sacrifice
the Baal children, rape them, and your
children, your children, by the American
children, getting raped by Israeli
officials in Las Vegas, and just getting
scot-free with the rape and back back to
Israel, the pedophile safe haven. Um,
and this is carrying on. And not only
that, they are now wanting you to
sacrifice your children for their great
Israeli plan, waiting for the
Antichrist. And the Zionist Christians
are like, "Yes, yes, we're going to do
this, because when Jesus comes, he's
going to uh kill all the uh the Jews,
whatever it's for that matter." So, as
you can see, this is how stupid you guys
are. Okay, and look at this, your
country is owned by Israel. This is
absolutely ridiculous. Can you imagine
your president is being blackmailed,
openly blackmailed, by these guys to go
to war with Iran? Well, here is Look at
this serviceman. And then he's going to
say, "Thank you very much. Give me more
of your children." And can this Owen
Skull disavow? Can this Owen say, "Today
they're coming for the Gaza children.
Tomorrow they're coming for you." And
they're exactly doing that. Your
children are dying
for the Israelis that hate you
Christians. They spit at you. In the
holy land, they spit at you. They
believe you as idol worshipers. Okay, if
anything, they believe that we are the
worshipers of one God, we can enter
paradise, etc. You know, they can even
come and pray in our mosques. But, they
despise you Christians, and you
Christians are subservient to them as
pleased. Okay, let's watch the video
inshallah of servicemen that died
um sadly in this war. Israel ramping up
attacks overnight on Tehran targeting
Iranian missile launchers and weapons
factories. Eyewitness News reporter Phil
Tate live outside the United Nations
with the very latest. Phil.
Yeah, Peter Charles and good morning as
the war with Iran enters a fifth day
we're learning new information about the
ongoing operations including the
identification of the American soldiers
who had died in the early hours of the
war. Meantime overnight Israel
intensifying their attacks against
Lebanon and Iran.
A wave of new attacks in the Middle
East. US Central Command reveals more
than 50,000 US troops are now in the
region up from the 35,000 previously
reported. And now we're seeing the faces
of some of the first American casualties
of the war in Iran. Captain Cody Cork,
Sergeant First Class Nicole Amor,
Sergeant First Class Noah T. Jones, and
Sergeant Decklin Cody, all from an Army
Reserve unit in Des Moines, Iowa. They
were among six Americans killed after an
Iranian missile hit a tactical
operations center in Kuwait. The US
commander in the Middle East now sharing
in-depth details about the ongoing US
operations. Many of you may remember the
shock and awe strikes of 2003.
The first 24 hours of this operation
were nearly double the scale. We've
already struck nearly 2,000 targets with
more than 2,000 munitions. Iran now
escalating attacks [music] on American
interests in the region.
An Iranian drone slamming into the US
consulate in Dubai.
The US embassy in Jordan also targeted.
An Iranian missile even hitting the
largest US base in the Middle East in
Qatar. No injuries reported. Now
questions are being raised about the
amount of artillery on both sides of the
conflict. Military officials say it
takes two or three interceptors to shoot
down one ballistic missile and experts
predict Iran has a stock pile of more
than 2,000. That's fueling concern that
Iran's supply of cheap drones could
exhaust the multi-million dollar
interceptor systems of the US and its
allies.
There you go. So, Americans, you send
your children
to die for pedophiles. And actually, you
know what was put really well. There was
a poster I done. Let me just open that
post cuz that post was it just wrapped
the whole matter up perfectly. Let me
just read it for you guys. So, here's
the picture.
And in the picture it says
a picture of a a woman crying, "I miss
you, but I need to go to Iran Iran to
kill the kids like you. If I don't, then
people who rape kids like you might go
to jail." In a nutshell, that is what
the war is about. They are either raping
your kids or sending them to die for
their greater Israel plan, for their
Messiah, supported by your American
dollars, by the Christian Zionists.
Zionist.
Bravo, you absolute morons.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.